hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to nether okay I
spawned in a new server in a new
location I don't know where I am because
I haven't checked the map yet but I took
a mad dash sprint to get to where I am
right now okay so I'm by some green area
which I'm assuming it's an irradiated
Park of death and destruction just like
was that okay I saw shadow a butterfly
you guys here came right for me
no everything wants to kill me like
usual look don't they know that I'm
gonna kill them first huh huh semi oh
that was me okay I thought I heard the
splishy-splashy of another character
washing his way towards his own dead
why is he wet here I don't even see
water why is it all splishy-splashy will
he to read there's a lot more stuff
that's been read place has been picked
over pretty well suddenly I'm examining
everything suddenly I can't get enough
of this lovely lovely world oh I got a
bad feeling about this
and again I always had a bad feeling
about everything I can't see a damn
thing I'm hoping that the day/night
cycle freaks out again suddenly puts me
into daylight because at this rate I
could be snuck up upon snuck up upon at
any given moment by both man and beast
man and beast
I'm gonna die I'm gonna die this is how
I die not going out in a blaze of glory
buddy getting sniped from a distance oh
it's wet again why is it always wet
what does it happen why you gotta be wet
why am I so on edge
oh no it's dark I don't trust the dark I
know that someone's gonna get me in the
dark I don't even see any goodies all
just black I want to happen to me
examining everything what what am I
looking at
wait where am I Oh am I still in the
building I thought I was outside for a
second there barely not okay I'm still
knee-deep in water I'm almost to the
edge of the place and then there's the
lake sides safe haven which where I left
smitty werben jaegerman jensen before
but I need to do more than that I need
aha a day/night cycle has flipped once
again and I'm able to see I can see
clearly now night is gone I can see all
obstacles in my way
I'm gonna cross the bridge again and I
know what happened last time
nothing that's exactly what they expect
me to expect to happen again I'm gonna
cross it as quick as possible
hope I don't die once again I didn't not
pick a low population server I'm
assuming here oh that's just an
ambulance flashing lights of death and
destruction coming towards me this is
the [ __ ] visit this is the big I
crossed before when I was in a panic I
know cuz there's a gas station right
there I will check out but only what I
know that it is safe what nice doesn't
hey hey I'll bet you're no smitty you're
no smitty werben jaegerman jensen I'm
gonna kill you I don't think I saw
anything I'm just being cautious just
yelling got random oh my me I'm normal
oh my me I'm perfectly normal in this
crazy world
hey I picked like the highest population
server I could find though I know it's
gonna be some guys I'm out of the
woodwork any minute now and this time
I'm not gonna hesitate cuz they are not
smitty werben jaegerman jensen they are
evil and they will kill me just like I
will kill that but I'll kill them first
because they were gonna kill me anyway
good wait what I see no no yes I don't
know why the lights go out there hey
another search is underway where oh by
the sea David maybe I should help him
what Oh paper blown in wood maybe not
Vicki
half of this game and half of me playing
this game is just like that's nothing
gonna happen in then nothing ever did I
even have room for that I think I did
apparently I do don't know why I picked
it up though why do I have so many pills
good fun I'm assuming those help my
health kind of adds a little bit they
can consolidate a little bit now is
there no apparently not help all right
never mind let's see anything one
industry get me out all right time to
stop being a baby
I'm the going guns-a-blazing huh crunchy
bins go back tax base and I got a drop
this and then I'll pick it up later the
pain pills put in yeah there we go okay
crunchy bands hold you to read you never
know what you might find in a place here
even though it's been stripped come on
pick up the crunchy fans don't know why
I really need him ah [ __ ] goddamn it
[ __ ] ass Wow
oh I shouldn't use my main gun ah where
the hell can you hit me through that
dick bag son of a fluffernutter gotta be
someone around here someone that I can
murder cuz I wanted to go out guns
blazing in this playthrough come on face
me coward not you wait who are you going
after going after someone you chasing
someone you look like you're chasing
someone
you look like someone's down there who's
down there
who's down there man oh you gave up oh
don't come after me hey are you going
are you going whoa big guy did you smash
up a survivor mister reminds me of this
time that I was in Canada did you know
that they have bagged milk in Canada I
know
very weird enough to warrant a trip up
there but I mean it reminds me of Canada
because of all the death and destruction
there Canada's this this barren
wasteland of nothingness I'm sorry
that's not what's down here I go down
here I can't I didn't know you could go
down here it's down here
besides you know whole lot of death some
reason I would not want to be trapped
down under cool toss something move
who's out there
who's out there somebody down here
anybody
anybody at all hiding in the nooks and
crannies just talking to myself again
oh is this a vendor guy no this is not
actually what is the point of this I'm
guessing that this is just flavor for
you know the environment makeshift
shelter that someone used to commandeer
the subway I didn't even know you
because it learn something new every day
looks like a barren wasteland of death
and destruction by the way sorry my
Canadian friends I didn't mean to insult
you so dearly
Canada is a lovely place I would suggest
going to Montreal very nice of the
Arctic better than America by Barker
there were like 40 something oh come on
what did I do
no you go down you stay down you fall
into that boards of wood also known as
like a platform or something I don't
know uh downed helicopter a it looks a
little dangerous but hey let's go for it
all right army rations I need to eat
that yeah tasty delicious
rocky bands what is a hat oh that's the
thing that I will I have right now hang
on let me we drop them stuff we drop
this real quick pick up the house unload
it cuz it should have ass enough I guess
stop it pick up crunchy bands Dan there
we go we're off not bad we're down
helical I like this perky bed I thought
it was actually gonna be something I
understand that a lot of people would
come around these part but apparently
yeah wait was that rusty something in
there
hi do see something in there some good
I don't even know why I have the gum
seems like totally useless I know you're
supposed to sell it but to me seems
pretty useless now don't drop it we go
we go where the hell did it just go it's
vanished into thin air you can't tell me
it vanished you son of a [ __ ] you just
got rid of it for me you [ __ ] how
dare you I was gonna use that I needed
those bull
can you cook them away from me I saw
something in here
ha - medium cash ten bucks all right I
wouldn't even think that in a
post-apocalyptic nightmare that people
would burn any value in money games like
a foolish thing to do actually all right
I noticed that there's this giant plume
of smoke right where this helicopter is
it's an awfully large signal for people
to find it though I'm assuming I need to
look for more smokestack to go for
burning wreckages of valuable thing
nope don't see any I'm gonna cross the
bridge again I'm gonna get back to the
mainland
Oh another burning wreckage a I think
it's still across the bay but I'll go to
that one need to not be careless I need
to keep my eyes open for other players
but still I welcome death at this point
is that a shotgun
holy hell it is I'm so taking that no
gimme gimme gimme gimme
come on drop this old gun if I can
unload it drop it
I'm picking up KB twelve baby all right
hello big boy oh crap
ah [ __ ]
I don't want to fight you prick I don't
want to fight you bruh I don't wanna
fight oh my god I'm such an ass I'm such
an ass
I need to get up high yeah ah fine you
want to dance
babban mmm humid you you're dead ah come
on what can I not get away you're that
big you aren't that tough you're
actually kind of a son of a [ __ ] we're
PT Oh more crunchy pens there's just
tons of food in here
wasn't that just a lightful for you I
don't need you I do need a bandage
however we'll jump you oh come on that
didn't fill me up fine
till your dad your dad bro your dad
hahahaha I finally got one you're coming
for the bullets you're gonna kill me I
knew you were it was right he was gonna
kill me oh I feel bad now but not that
bad
front see Ben's row max I don't need any
of that haha he jumped up on me actually
surprised me I didn't have a choice in
the matter came to tell me I didn't do
it he came to kill me you all start he
wanted to kill me dad and I I got shot
off first
I didn't laugh maniacally after I kill
them what are you talking about I don't
know what you're talking about and
frankly I don't like your attitude I'm
not a murderer I'm not a murderer
I bet in a nation no turning into one of
them
Mukesh yes I know I must resist the
urges whoa evil bastard juice I never
did no harm to no one of those people
that I killed all of them to take their
stuff and run away as fast as I can or
if there's a way to carry more stuff you
know stuff that you pillage off the dead
bodies of others
is someone there ready to be murdered
murdered so delightfully by the likes of
me yeah there's no time to reminisce bro
we gotta get going
there's wow what was that that a snipers
glare was he about to kill me dead I
think he was I think that's what that
was
oh my goodness that might have been the
glare of a snipey snoop I will not be
taken so easily
I have Ione Snivy snoo actually I have
no idea what that what that might have
just been like a spotlight or something
may not have actually been a snakey
snoop I'm an ass tomb that was in US
Navy don't kill me
I mean innocent not really but I'm kind
of I feel bad I know that I don't feel
bad either
oh no support it up I'm going the wrong
way I don't know what else to say it is
almost the end of day also seems to be
sometime in May
oh those bastards are gonna pay ha ha ha
ha I got nothing else that rhymes with
say the monsters will come out and play
but maybe they will go home and stay all
they can do is get on their knees and
pray oh how their skin I shall play aah
what is it
what is it did it just spotlight okay
nevermind I was wrong
a panic I panicked over nothing
I panty anyways see any other players
he's doing one don't tell her I was here
cuz I'm probably gonna shoot up in the
face a lot like a whole lot like way
more bullets than is needed to kill a
human being but all in the face
technically probably only need like one
in the face I'm gonna do more than that
look a lot more who can i cal yeah hey
what are you doing guarding that thing
you get away from there hah ah come on
what the hell I knew to you guys besides
kill while I kill whoa ah [ __ ] what's
up - I'll bring it on I still don't know
if those things like dropped on any good
for me but great if ice is prepared
what the hell is that mean you made
devices repaired well you think I am
some kind of Good Samaritan that's gonna
guide repair all of your devices baby I
don't know seems to be one more after me
I'm gonna need to switch my guns up here
in a little bit in a metal bit hi
down you [ __ ] I'm level 11 you don't
want to mess with level 11
you're bad there's no goodies around
here what the hell crashed helicopter no
goodies Wow a pile of asses
alright guys that's about all the time I
got for this one I actually went over
and started cutting it up a bit just to
keep it a bit more fresh and interesting
I got one kill all right and the rest
were just job's downs or whatever you
want to call them nether I guess but
anyway I don't know how many more of
these parts I'm gonna make Raj is gonna
go until this particular character dies
but he's been rather tenacious wouldn't
you say go anyway thank you all so much
for watching click in these videos that
I've done and as always I will see you
in the next video
three I mean I love
there are all these weird noises I don't
I don't know where it's coming from the
way the movement works it's very
restrictive so that I feel like a like
there's something behind me and I can't
respond very quickly if it's there it
kind of waited ah secret